look Dave you and Bill Mah and Elon Musk
are great examples of people who for
most of your life you you were
considered yourself left of center and
and what happened I think Elon put it
beautifully when he tweeted out a
spectrum of right to left and he had the
middle and he was left of center and
then the whole Spectrum moved like crazy
and he's like what the hell happened I
didn't move at all and suddenly suddenly
he's right of Center because the left
has gone to Crazy Town listen when I was
on Bill Mah it was awesome i' never met
bill I didn't know him at all and and I
started by by telling him I said bill I
think what you're doing is really
important you're an old school liberal
there are a lot of issues you and I
disagree on but you believe in free
speech that now makes you a radical
conservative because you don't want to
silence anyone who disagrees with you
and I pointed out I said look on your
show you actually have people from right
and left I said there's virtually no
show on television that has discussion
and I believe if we don't talk to each
other that we're going to lose the
country all right Senator Ted Cruz I
don't think you need an intro do you
need an intro at this point what's the
you're a senator I'm just thrilled to be
back you're from Texas you beat me in
Nintendo wrestling years ago people get
it and you have a new book unwoke uh how
to defeat cultural Marxism in America I
guess my main question to you is in
light of everything happening in the
world right now the fact that we're
rolling into a presidential election
next year the two months uh since these
horrific attacks November 7th and
everything else we have to give the woke
credit they have destroyed so much of
our sense making and it sort of feels
obvious that this is the moment we're in
right well Dave that's exactly right and
it's it's why I wrote the book because
because I I think we are at a level of
Crisis you and I have never seen it's
never happened in our lifetime and and
what's happened what what what the book
does is it
explains how the radical left sees just
about every major institution in our
country so it starts with universities
and each chapter of the book focuses on
a different institutions so chapter one
is universities I I call universities
the Wuhan lab of the woke virus that's
where that's where it was invented it's
where it mutated it's where it spread it
goes from universities to K through2
education from there to journalism from
there to government from there to Big
Business to Big Tech to entertainment
Hollywood movies television music Sports
from there to science and then the last
chapter is on China which I think is a
central Nexus that is intertwined with
all of them and what the book does is
number one it lays out how and why the
radical left took over each of these
institutions but then number two even
more critically it lays out a positive
proactive battle plan for here's how we
take them back cuz I think if we don't
take the ins tions back we're going to
lose our country what does it say about
our institutions all the institutions
that you just mentioned there from
cultural to political to entertainment
and everything else that they all
seemingly folded to this thing and it
and it happened on all of our watches I
mean I I include all of us in that yes
well listen it was deliberate and the
book explains it goes back to the 1960s
you look at at Marxist look Marxism as
you know originates with KL Marx Karl
Marx laid out a view in The Communist
Manifesto that viewed viewed the world
as fundamentally in conflict and it's a
conflict between oppressors and victims
and Marx viewed it in socioeconomic
terms so the oppressors were the owners
of capital the victims were the
proletariat the working men and women
and the solution that Marx advocated for
was the violent revolution of the
victims the proletariat to overthrow
their oppressors and use government
power to forcibly redistribute the
wealth well what happened is in the
1960s and70s the marxists began began
infiltrating universities they began
becoming tenur faculty and
administrators and from there it mutated
and you began to see different prisms
put on Marxism so critical race theory
is the same conflict lens but it's based
on race instead of socioeconomic status
queer theory is the same thing but based
on gender and gender identity in every
instance it's a fundamental conflict and
supporting the violent revolution of the
so-called uh victims and and you know
you talked a minute ago about what's
happening on college campuses The
Vicious anti-Semitism we're seeing on
college campuses that is a manifestation
of the rot of cultural Marxism I was
talking recently with a fellows a very
successful businessman in Silicon Valley
and he's a man of the left he's been a
Democrat his whole life and he was
expressing horror at at where this
anti-Semitism was coming from and
confusion like where where did it happen
and I explained I said look for the
radical leftist they have defined Jews
as oppressors and they have defined
Palestinians as victims and once they do
that for the cultural Marxist the policy
they support is the violent revolution
of the so-called victims against the
oppressors and it's why you see black
lives matter and University students and
professors cheering for the Hamas
terrorists because any violence any
horror is Justified for the Marxist once
it is the so-called victim overthrowing
the oppressor are you hopeful that at a
national level we can reverse this I
mean you know I'm in Florida where we're
doing an awful lot to push against it
you're in Texas where you're doing an
awful lot but it seems to me when I see
these rallies in New York City and in
Chicago in these Democrat run cities I
don't see any will to stop any of this
stuff so Dave I really am optimistic and
and I'm hopeful and and and what the
book unwoke does is I said it lays out a
battle plan for here here's how we turn
it around and I really focus on on three
buckets of tools that we can use to take
the institutions back bucket one is
sunlight and transparency because the
ideas of the radical left are wildly
unpopular and simply exposing them as a
powerful tool against them normal
rational people don't support abolishing
the police normal rational people don't
support open borders and the chaos at
our Southern border normal rational
people don't root for Hamas terrorists
and so sunlight is powerful secondly
what I advocate is changing the cost
benefit analysis and in particular
increasing the cost for individuals and
for institutions to go W increasing the
disincentives and then third what I
advocate can you give me a little detail
can you give me a little detail on
number two because I think that's the
key one people think they can now just
get away with anything at all at with no
cost well let's take for for example the
chapter I have on big business I do a
deep dive into what happened with with
budlight and Target and Disney and in
all three instances you had companies
that put woke ideology above their
customers they tried to jam it down
their customers customers throats and in
all three instances the companies faced
billions of dollars of losses and and
and what that did is it I believe
changed the incentive for the next CEO
thinking about am I going to go woke
suddenly the downside of doing so is
much more significant I also talk in the
book about a bill that the state of
Texas passed it was called Senate Bill
13 and it provided if you boycott oil
and gas oil and gas provides millions of
jobs in the state of Texas Texas said if
you boycott oil and gas the state of
Texas will boycott you and in particular
we will not invest in your fund Texas
Pension funds Texas endowments we've got
hundreds of billions of dollars of
capital and if you're going to wage war
on jobs in Texas we're not going to help
you on that that was a bill that I
advocated I urged the legislature to
pass they did pass and I'll tell you
it's put the fear of God in Wall Street
and I've urged other red States change
the cost benefit analysis make it
expensive to go woke and we're seeing
real victories by using economic power
to fight back what do you think we can
do to get those s liberals that you
referenced uh before to come around and
actually vote the right way you know I
saw you on Real Time with Bill Maher a
couple weeks ago Jordan Peterson was on
a couple weeks ago Elon Musk was on a
couple weeks ago I was on Friday Bill
strikes me as the bellweather for what a
sane liberal can do I don't know that he
can get there but but he represents the
type of person that I think ultimately
could vote Republican what do we
especially in a place like Texas a lefty
who's waking up what do we do for those
people look you and Bill Mah and Elon
Musk are great examples of people who
for most of your life you you were
considered yourself left of center and
and what happened I think Elon put it
beautifully when he tweeted out a
spectrum of right to left and he had the
middle and he was left of center and
then the whole Spectrum moved like crazy
and he's like what the hell happened I
didn't move at all and suddenly suddenly
he's right of Center because the left
has gone to Crazy Town listen when I was
on Bill Mah it was awesome I'd never met
bill I didn't know him at all and and I
started by by telling him I said bill I
think what you're doing is really
important you're an old school liberal
there are lot of issues you and I
disagree on but you believe in free
speech that now makes you a radical
conservative because you don't want to
silence anyone who disagrees with you
and I pointed out I said look on your
show you actually have people from right
and left I said there's virtually no
show on television that has discussion
and I believe if we don't talk to each
other that we're going to lose the
country and and so I think Elon Musk had
never voted Republican until two years
ago Myra Flores was the first Republican
he ever cast a ballot for and and I do
think listen we have the opportunity
I've been a conservative my whole life
but I think as conservatives we can
defend very simple Common Sense
propositions things like free speech you
know it's it's not
symmetrical the left wants to silence
their opponents the right doesn't I
don't want to silence Bernie I don't
want to silence AOC I want everyone to
hear their idiocies and I agree with
John Stewart Mill the best best response
to bad speech is more speech and and and
so I think we have an opportunity to be
engaged in in in in simply common sense
and to be happy Warriors if someone
wants to be a socialist great but you
know what they better be prepared to
defend the murder the torture the misery
and the suffering that communism has
produced all over the world and and one
of the things going back to the book
unwoke you know I start the book by
telling my father's story as you know
Dave my father was born in Cuba grew up
in Cuba and he fought in the in the
Communist Revolution in Cuba he was
imprisoned and tortured in Cuba and and
I tell that story he was 14 years old
when he started fighting alongside Fidel
Castro and and and one of the points I
make is is that Marxist always always
always start with young people you look
at every Communist Revolution across the
globe it is teenagers who are young and
impressionable and passionate and they
don't have the like life experience to
have wisdom it is why the left targets
universities and targets K through2
education because they indoctrinate and
and quickly let me get to the third
bucket of tools yep which is that we
need to be fighting in the arena of
ideas and in particular taking over the
organs of transmission of of ideas what
you do Dave is incredibly important this
podcast is incredibly important I do a
podcast three days a week verdict with
Ted Cruz we need to be creating
alternative Avenues to communicate and I
urge conservatives and Libertarians with
resources who've been successful at
business
invest in in acquiring organs of
transmission of ideas buy a TV station
buy a radio station buy a book
publishing house buy a movie studio buy
a record label and the example I use is
Elon musk's buying Twitter was I think
the single most important step for free
speech in decades I discuss it a lot uh
in the book on woke so let me just en
encourage your viewers you can get on
woke anywhere you get books Amazon
Barnes & Noble go buy it and I'll
mention to you it it it's obviously the
holiday season the book I I think makes
a great Christmas gift and so buy it for
your mom buy it for your best friend buy
it for your crazy left-wing neighbor
that you want to knock some sense into
or even better buy it for your kids or
your grandkids so that they can
understand what it is that that people
are trying to indoctrinate you with and
and and they can have the tools to to to
know how to fight back a senator and a
Salesman very professional my friend all
right senator now you have two reasons
to come down to Miami I know you got to
jump because we're going to play ball
when I get my finger fixed which I'm
working on and we're going to go down to
Caye oo and drink some Mojitos in Little
Havana cuz the Cubans if any if there
are any people in America right now who
get what freedom is it is the Cuban and
I'm sure they'll be happy to see you and
Dave I'll say we will do both of those
and and and when you're in DC as you
know I play Hoops twice a week in fact
it's Tuesday morning right now Tuesday
afternoon we're going to be playing
Hoops if you're here I'll warn you our
game I is more violence than it is skill
so so so you broke a finger not too long
ago one of my staff members broke my
thumb I went up for a rebound he jammed
it down in my thumb as I told my
13-year-old daughter daddy said a very
bad word but but but you'd be proud even
with a broken thumb we finished the game
we won and miraculously I scored with a
broken thumb I did a finger roll I
couldn't shoot I screamed when I tried
to shoot but I did a finger roll and
scored a bucket with a broken thumb and
so you know persistence and being
stubborn in hell sometimes is better
than actually having skill listen next
time you come on we're going to do a 52y
old and a 47y old just explaining all of
their uh career injuries Senator it was
great to see you thanks thanks man if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop screaming check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell